à
je la trouve sensible
elle a bon caractère
elle est adorable depuis ton petit
on voit ces jeunes lui avale aguerris
j'ai 28 ans mon nom d'artiste ces jeunes
athena est donc je travaille
principalement autour de la thématique
des rêves et des mythes et légendes et
j'utilise pour ça des supports je suis
faible que le dessin la vidéo ou la
photo
c'est que c'est une grosse grosse bosse
c'est à dire elle vit pour son art elle
dort elle travaille en dormant
puisqu'elle travaille entre autres sur
les rêves elle elle travaille
constamment elle est toujours en
réflexion elle est toujours en train de
griffonner elle est elle toujours en
train de faire des recherches pour son
travail
ce dauphin là ils représentent une des
légendes qui dit que lorsqu'on va au
niveau des cimetières le soir et tout ça
donc on risque de
de ramener des âmes avec nous et du coup
c'est un peu un monstre qui représente
un petit peu ces âmes perdues donc là
ici on voit en fait les barreaux de
cimetière donc le mans c'est l'effet de
ces barreaux et puis des bougies dès
qu'elles ressortent en fait des petits
personnages comme ça
bonjour bonjour ma chérie elle fait des
dessins je me demande où ça passe pas
comment elle réfléchit pour faire céder
saad a cessé d idées qui viennent tout
seuls a dit et qui viennent toutes
seules
donc à mon avis elle le fait pour ça
mais ça me touche beaucoup parce que moi
même je me suis demandé comment elle
fait pour faire tout ça ce qui
m'intéresse c'est que les gens lorsqu il
la regarde mais qui retrouve une
histoire qui leur est propre et à partir
de ce moment là bas il ya un lien qui se
crée entre l'oeuvre entre la personne
entre l'artiste mais aussi entre toutes
les personnes qui ont cette histoire
personnelle là
on
à